come on
all right ishii ishii where'd you grow
up where are you from
originally um compton california compton
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were growing
up um
i was raised with my grandmother both my
parents are on drugs
so mom and dad were not really in your
life yeah
and how would you describe your
childhood loss
what kind of stuff went on life
depression abuse
disappointment failure
i mean would you say what kind of abuse
molestation um physical abuse
abandonment
then your grandmother didn't protect you
no it happened to her too and she didn't
know how to
handle it was it who
was your grandfather no um two uncles
one
molest me and the other beat me
and how far did you go to school i
graduated a year early from high school
and where'd you go from there i went to
college you did
i went for nursing you know
after that i got married at 19
to a truck driver that used to transport
drugs for my family
um he grew on me i it was a must i had
to marry him i married him
it was abusive relationship my whole
sided face got fractured
um i have a
a cricket back from him um running me
over
with a truck
and um we got divorced
and i got married again
it was happy it was good
first time in my life i was happy and
was loved
and um he got killed i was pregnant
i had his child and a year later
i lost my son accident's mother-in-law
i started selling drugs our house got
raided and he took my daughter
i quit my job i was home how many how
many kids do you have i just have one
um i designed and
printed latex and foil balloons
like in walmart and
i worked there for 18 years and after my
husband died
so you told me how many kids you had
just one it would have been three but
it's just one
um my daughter was a twin his name was
sean
and um i didn't even know i was having
twins he hid behind my daughter
and when i gave birth he had came and
he was here for about three months and
um he passed away
i'm sorry i'm from suds
um i held on
it's just after my first love passed
away and
his son to uh his seat i just lost it
i just went downhill and um
i haven't came back
it's hard because i'm out here alone
no family one child
no support system because i'm scared of
people
how they hurt you in that beauty
so i just stay alone
i've been alone going for five years
five years no contact with the world no
tv
nothing
what about your child what about your
child
i just got her back um she's nine
her name is sierra afini shakur
um she's wonderful no matter what i went
through she's
she's she's a beautiful angel
now um that i do have her back i'm
getting a little bit
back focused um i have a wonderful man
in my life who was helping for me
and that's really
having patience and trust
in god that i will come out of this
and i've never had that before
not to give up on me when i give up on
myself
anyone in your family
i have no family i'm the only child on
my mom's side
um i'm the sixth child on my dad's side
the youngest and the only girl
but because i am black
my mom black and their spanish they
don't accept
me
and are drugs are part of the picture
for you
yes it's um a numb um
i do methamphetamine
it's a numb for me but
it's been so long it don't even work
anymore um
now just take paint pills
to go to sleep or just to
know my thoughts
this is not where i want to be it's not
where i came from
but i believe in god now and
things have gotten a little easier um me
and my daughter is not on the streets
anymore
she's home i just
i don't know i'm just lost i don't
i'm just lost
i've never been so lost in my life i've
always
had a plan a plan b back up
something have you you've had jobs
yes um for 18 years
i designed balloons and printed them um
and for two years
i um i re remodeled walmarts
yes city to city state to state
you're not working currently no i
currently got laid off
seven months ago and after i got laid
off
i really really hit rock bottom i went
into depression
i had to go to a a mental institution
i had to get on meds
i tried to commit suicide twice
it's just an ugly situation
with depression and drugs don't help
intensifies
[Music]
intensifies
a lot of these people who are on drugs
out here and skid row
really just need some love
but you have to start with yourself and
i lost that
i lost it so now that i
don't really
care for myself nothing even matters
no more sometimes not even my daughter
because i feel like i'm feeling as
a parent i'm feeling as
a woman
it's hard
it's hard
it's hard to feel better about yourself
and hard to do better for yourself when
you feel so bad about yourself
i start believing in god
i start believing in god and
now the drugs don't even get me high
so that's why i went to pain pills and
now those are not even
working but you still need them to feel
good yes
yes
what do you think may have changed your
direction in your life when you were
young like if your parents were an
addict
perhaps that might have been the biggest
thing
the biggest thing is
going through pain and no one's there
for you
going through something and no one's
there for you
crying out for help and no one comes
no one comes
and it hurts it hurts when you love
people and they're for people and no
one's coming for you
when you cry out for help
[Applause]
the most thing um
the most pain even the musician
is my son knowing
that he's not here because of me
he'll be three on the 16th of this month
this was your other child this is my
last son yes
and what happened with him
i accidentally smothered him
i went back to work too soon
i shouldn't even went back to work and i
did a 12 hour shift
but this particular night i was just so
tired
i didn't even put him in his bed i
didn't even take our clothes off
and i'm so used to not sleeping with him
i forgot
i forgot
i forgot
oh my god he was there
and that's all that i had of my husband
the first man the first person to really
love me
and show me what life was about
joyfully
so he died in the bed with you i slept
on him
i slept on him he was in the bed with me
yes
i smothered him i wrote on them
um was up under investigation
for six months so they came in my house
see how i worked with my other child um
that lasted for a little bit when i got
raided
that's when they came and they took my
daughter and they took my daughter for
six months
she came home
and they had me up under investigation
for my son so then that's when they came
in
and they started living in my house for
six months to see how
how i react to my daughter and my abuse
of
do i yell do i scream you know things
like that
and then i lost her again
i took her to work with me i didn't have
a babysitter i took her to work with me
and they called um cps on me
i was on i was using
meth and people at my job in town
so they call cps on me and i took my
daughter to work with me and i was using
meth and they drug tested me
and they took her again this time they
kept her for two years
so i cleaned up for two years just to
get my daughter back
and um i went through a breakup
before she got home and it tore me up
and it got me back on drugs
i got pregnant at them i had a
miscarriage
and it was a trigger
it was a trigger and it got me back on
track so i've been back on meth
for two months now
for two months
but god's not ready for me because i
didn't try suicide
three times it's not my time to go so i
know i have a purpose
your daughter is old she's nine to nine
she's with you
yes so
today what this is my second day being
sober
no math i'm going to detox
because i have a wonderful person that
believes in me
more than i believe in myself
so help me go through this and don't
judge me and love me
and my daughter
so it gives me hope
it gives me hope and i know that there's
a god he was listening to my prayers
glenn is my angel
and i know he's my angel said
because i asked god to send someone for
me and me and my daughter was just being
funny
to make sure that we know that he was
sent from god
for him to have two colored eyes
clean's a good guy and he have two
different color eyes
so i know that god sent him to help me
get better and get clean
because that's what i asked for
four men to have two different kind of
eyes and they have two different colors
so i know there's a god and there is
hope
and i believe that
so that's why i'm on my second day clean
because i know
i know there's hope and there's a god
let me get through this
he took me and my daughter out of a tent
well off the streets we didn't have a
tent in home
we're in a mobile home now he took us
off
the bus stop to a tent and then from a
tent to a mobile home
and now um section 8 came through
so we're going to move from a mobile
home to our own apartment
and this man don't even know me and my
daughter
[Music]
so we went from sleeping on a bus stop
to almost our own home
so i know
i just get depressed around this time
because i know my son birthday is coming
and i haven't forgave my
[Music]
self from my soul
what was your son's name his name was
damarion
omaru shakur
and he would be three on the 16th
you know he just wants you to be happy
yes
[Music]
i know that's what keeps me going now
um we have so much going on and so many
losses
you forget what you have
and i forgot about her
i forgot about her
i forgot how important
i was to someone
instead of someone being
important to me i forgot
that no matter what this one person
would love me no matter what
regardless drugs or no drugs
she loves me no matter what and that's
now that i see
it gives me it gives me strength
so that's why i'm on day two
of being sober of being on math
been on meth for five years
i'm on day two
and i have a long way to go but i'm not
gonna give up
take care of your daughter but number
one you take care of yourself yes
because if you take care of yourself
your daughter is going to be just fine
yes it's not easy
and i'm not saying it is but
[Music]
a step a step to take your long
way very far
[Music]
and believe if you don't believe in god
at least believe in yourself
[Music]
and you start somewhere well you find
the best person on skid row
[Music]
this is the second person in my life
that i've had
[Music]
that i don't worry that he's gonna hurt
me
he's not gonna ban me he's not gonna
judge me
and treat my daughter and take my
daughter in as she was his
and that don't happen here in 2020.
i'm easy asara shakur
and that's my story
thank you
i know he is i know he is
i was just talking about him in the
morning so we prayed
never in a million years
and i didn't see it my daughter pointed
it out
[Music]
i'm not sure it's about the eyes